exactly a year ago at San Francisco we
introduced this new division at the
Microsoft called the Microsoft AI in the
research and we actually have the
mission to democratize AI for everyone
so it has been a very exciting year in
the 2017 and there has been we expect it
and they delivered to be in a very
exciting year so I'm here to share some
of the progress with you I appreciate
this opportunity to show you especially
some very practical ways that AI is
helping everyone to improve our lives so
everyone is talking about AI nowaday but
AI is really not new you know AI was
really the something that really the
automated goal that for brilliant minds
people like Alan Turing you know those
people you imagine that someday if we
have this unbelievable computing power
what could we really do the first thing
that Alan Turing really imagined was
doing a AI is really mimicking in the
human intelligence and that the
Microsoft our very own Bill Gates you
know when he created Microsoft Research
20 60 years ago and he imagined that in
a some day computers could see hear talk
and understand the human beings you know
that's really generalized the AI and AI
is now happening fast
you know why is that Jimmie's released
three forces that converging to make
this thing happen it's really the big
data in the morning always the web who
is IOT and everything and the massive
computing power especially the clouds
but most recently especially with bricks
through algorithms like deep learning a
deep neural nets I really moved the AI
from the labs to the mainstream so today
we are going to talk to you about
everyday AI it's really you know the AR
is available you know to everyone
everywhere you know and whatever you do
in your personal and professional life
so how a AI is going to help
in many ways if you just read articles
in the general press AI probably has
gotten a bad reputation
you know because much of the AI
discussing is about you know humans
versus machines but not enough about AI
potentials we know AI will transform
every business you know help in every
life and potentially solve some of those
societal challenges that we all face and
you might ask that that's all sounds
great but what about the Microsoft AI
was so unique about what we do at the
Microsoft about AI well we believe that
AI know comes down to one thing people
AI will amplify human ingenuity making
people the heroes and the driving are
healthy connection between humans and
machines that's what we believe at
Microsoft
after that's really about the Microsoft
the mission that is empower every person
and every organization on the planet to
achieve more now I would even add with
AI it's really a powerful machine and
the not too long ago our CEO Satya
Nadella shared our worldview that is the
intelligent the clouds and the
intelligent edge infused by AI you know
in a way it's really about the
ubiquitous computing and the ambient
intelligence finally happening
with PCs phones and the Monomoy IOT
devices just the imagine that you walk
into any room you know you walk to your
speaker you walk to your screen or you
don't even even realize that those
things they happen in the existing in
the room then you can already you know
talk to katana to get things done you
know maybe across the room with the help
of far feel the cameras and the far few
the speakers so our goal is really to
help everyone everywhere and take
advantage of AI every day so that's
exactly why sake and I actually created
our AI in the research division and a
little over a year ago
it has been a really exciting year and
with more than 8,000 researchers and
engineers - walking together very
closely and we make angry the progress
and the in particular will leverage the
talent and the technology coming out of
our Microsoft research labs by
accelerating the cycle from research to
the product and the take a quick look at
the video about some exciting things
that we have been doing last year
you
actually you know how we even help
people you know without the voice is how
they can communicate using AI and
clearly I could use some help we're here
to is oh yeah our products and into the
hands
[Music]
it's great to see ideas and technologies
that have come Mac in the middle of our
products and into the hands of our users
you have lunch with Tony at CJ's from
12:30 to 1:30 p.m. it's changing the way
that we work with the land and it's
changing the way the land works for us
[Music]
top and left edge is not visible called
steady lease agreement
[Music]
hey Cortana yeah what's my schedule
today AI is gonna change everyday life
our goal is that we make it a lot better
for people
[Applause]
[Music]
well this is of course it's just a small
sample of you know so many things
happening in Microsoft a I&R and I want
to explain to you know those areas that
we actually make investments there are
really five things that we do in
Microsoft a inr and we started with
Microsoft research and it was a lot of
no groundbreaking aii technologies there
then we build a lot of AI products in
the products like in the Bing and the
katana you know helping you in with
everyday lives and we infusing AI into
all Microsoft products you know with
Windows in the office and many others
and we built in the AI platforms is
really a truly a cloud in the a I
platform that will can help Microsoft
developers and the ponders to build
their AI applications and we also see
incredible opportunities there with AI
solutions practically you know every
vertical you know industry is going to
be disrupted you know whether it's
health care or transportation and every
horizontal business processes what is
marketing sales or customer support and
will be disrupted by AI so we see
incredible opportunities there but let
me first of all show you a few
highlights the the coolest technology we
have developed from MSR Microsoft
Research you know getting into the real
products the first example I want to
talk to you is on speech recognition
just a few months ago we announced that
we for the first time ever now we
actually have the speech recognition
system that match in a human parity in
terms of error rate there has been this
you know standard the data set in the
United States called a switchboard data
set that was initially in a set up by
topper in the 25 years ago so the human
error rate is around 5.1 percent I'm not
even talking about the ordinary humans
who I'm talking about the professionals
who do transcript you know who is the
deep neural net with massive computing
power and with the brilliance of our
researchers so we finally enriched in
the human parity and then 5.1%
in the second area I want to talk to you
is actually machine reading
comprehension or natural language
understanding
last year we acquired this
montreal-based deep learning company
called the maluma you know they do you
know amazing work you know you're
reading and the writing and the machine
reading comprehension you will see more
on the moment loop our technologies get
into microsoft products in office in
being in other places the third area is
actually in machine translation so we
have been doing machine translation for
long long timing in our research labs
but now you can get machine translation
in many many products a few years ago we
shipped the machine translation in Skype
translator last year we actually shipped
a microsoft translator in iOS and other
mobile apps and the just a month ago you
know with great partnership with the
hard way now we're actually shipping
machine translator in those highways
flagship phones like May 10 and clearly
that you know with all those comparison
data we see that we now have the most
accurate machine translator on any
mobile phones today actually the
highways May 10 so those are the really
exciting things you know in you know you
research with the technology and we move
into mainstream products and I want to
talk about AI platform as well just
imagine what would like that if all the
developers could use all those cool
technology that we have in Microsoft and
from our labs
what if we actually make them available
especially through our cloud platform so
we actually have one of the most
comprehensive
cloud plus AI platforms on the market
you know there are really three pieces
that I want you to understand as we talk
about AI platforms this is the services
that we can offer and is the
infrastructure is AI on data and AI
compute and there's also tools like
Visual Studio Tools Visual Studio you
know tools for AI that we recently
shipped and there is limited a time
today I'm going to no just a deep dive
into some of the services that we are
actually already shipping so first of
all I'd like to
share with you that you know more than
you know 760,000 developers are already
using Microsoft cognitive services and
this is a great set of web api's you
know
developers can just take them and
they'll weave into their own
applications and it's really great to
see the mix of the customers like a
Mosin course and UPS or a healthcare how
they have been using Microsoft's
cognitive services and we really want to
help every developer to become an AI
developer it's not only just our
partners at the Microsoft that we use
cognitive services to to create a unique
user experiences one of my favorite is
this little app called the CAI we
actually launched in July it's an app
using computer vision AI technology to
help the blind and the visually impaired
and it's amazing to see that more than a
hundred thousand downloads already
happens and it's it has a reading of 4.8
you know it's really very touching to me
you know how you know we can actually
create the apps that people really
depend on and this read the response
from the community and today we are
releasing even more greater features you
know for you know seeing AI app such as
currency recognition color recognition
and the lida detection I encourage you
to take time after this and stop by
their booths and the checkout and you
will learn in the degree to user design
questions there you know how you can
even take those technology helper people
who couldn't really see very well you
know it makes you think about the design
very differently you know like using
different modalities to help so this is
just a one example the other thing we
very feel very very good about that we
know you know it's really helpful to the
developers is that among all those 30
you know API so we already shipped one
of them is called the language your
understanding you know service is called
the Lewis you know that is really really
you know pocketing very very popular
and the customers like it Dixon's
Carphone saber and the human interact
and we really appreciate their help you
know giving us the feedback and helped
us to get the product to certain quality
you know today you know I'm very happy
to announce that you know Lewis now is
GA is generally available so it's very
very exciting and another thing and I
want to talk about today you know
helping the developers is actually as
you're about services you know many many
companies you know companies like a
progressive Unilever publicist you know
they want to be the bots and the apps to
interact with the customers with the
employees the much like you know just
you know we talk to each other just like
a humans and we offer the as you about
the service not only help you to create
the BOTS but also help you to deploy the
BOTS and also help you to run your BOTS
and we already have a 240,000 developers
using as your pod services even in the
preview format but today we're
announcing that it's gianna so it's very
exciting and of course you know we
realize that you know as we develop an
AI you know we really have to drive the
connection with the AI community and the
to democratize AI is not just the one
company's responsibility is really the
whole community's responsibility I'll
give you a few examples here what we
have been doing at the Microsoft the
first example is this intermediate
representation this thing called onyx
it's got an open neural network exchange
project that we started with Facebook in
September it's really in the open source
format that enables those AI frameworks
to interoperate with each other so this
is example number one the second example
is actually what we have been doing with
Amazon is called the glue on so glue on
is that the AI in the framework
interface you know there are so many AI
in the frameworks out there and we don't
want the developers to be confused you
know they can choose any of this
framework and they can get help from
Amazon and Microsoft estado is something
called glue on to bypass all those
complexity without the sacrifice
any of those speed and the third example
I want to share with you is that you
know we have been making a lot of
investments you know with Microsoft
venture in those leading AI companies
emerging the companies there and there's
some great examples I show here like
element AI and the Banzai and the text
so those are very exciting activities
that we do and another thing I want to
share with you is that we see those
vertical solutions and very very
exciting and especially one example you
know we actually really push hard at
Microsoft that together with our
partners that is the business AI
solutions for customer services and I'm
sure you know at some point of your life
you use customer services and there and
typically you know you use customer
services you spend a lot of time in a
uni and you still get the frustrated
this is where AI can really come in to
help you know the system oh can you
imagine is actually you can have a
virtual agent and you have an aging
assistance and the conversation of
management to to bring all those in
together we have great partners like HP
Macy's and the Australian Government's
Department of Human Services already
working with us to deliver those
fantastic
solutions so those are really exciting
things that we have been doing in
Microsoft era in our but today I want to
focus on everyday AI I want you to talk
about what are those the practical ways
so what are those products that we're
already shipping with new and the cool
AI features to really help everyone
everyday so let me start with one of
those most pervasive forms of AI is
called the search and you might say so
what's new in search I have been using
such a for long long time and I would
argue that such has really moved on is
no longer just 10 blue links now in a
search can be so powerful with the
concepts you know with dialogues with
many more things and the Microsoft we
have buda bing really beyond just a
search engine Bing has helped to build a
Microsoft cloud
services with all those back-end
infrastructure and the Bing has become
the foundation for AI for our company
and B might be just a much bigger than
you even think about and we actually
launched the Bing in year 2007 and it is
now powering over a third of the PC web
search traffic in the United States and
the continues to grow you know in the US
and the worldwide and it also powers
some such experiences from many of our
partners including Yahoo now is Verizon
ll in the Amazon and the multilingual
ability of Twitter and Apple's image
research of course you know through
search we have developed some really
foundational AI technologies especially
in natural language understanding so
this is really you know a lot of a lot
of things that we can depend on for the
future ai development so today I'm very
very excited to introduce three new
intelligent search capabilities that we
shipping immediately with Bing the first
thing is what we call the intelligent
answers so that utilizes the machine
reading comprehension to present you
with multiple perspectives
share snippets of multiple answers
verify answers across multiple sources
and the translates data into easy to
understand the concepts so it's not only
you see more on the models answers
popping up at the top of the searcher is
out the page from Bing but you will get
a lot more perspective as well second
intelligent image research that enables
you to search image within the images
you know by leveraging object
recognition so that's another cool way
to find what you are really looking for
the third new feature about the new
intelligent searching being is what I
call a conversational search that really
provides the intelligent
suggestions to help you to find what you
are really looking for very often we
understand that we want to search for
something but it's really hard to
express what if we actually turn that
experience engine more a dialogue so
that's the third thing called the
conversational search